das hier ist das legendäre the rock
French Toast das Herzstück ist ein
besonders dickes briochebrot 34 cm die
sich vollsaugen mit unserer French Toast
Mischung und für die brauchen wir Milch
braunen Zucker Vanilleextrakt Zimt eine
Prise Salz und zwei Eier jetzt verkölen
wir das Ganze und lassen das Brioche die
Flüssigkeit aufsaugen 30 Minuten sollten
reichen währenddessen können wir uns um
die Soße kümmern die besteht aus
Erdnussbutter Ahornsirup und Kokosmilch
und sie könnte nicht einfacher sein wir
müssen Sie einfach nur für rühren und
fertig ist die perfekte French toastsße
dann können wir auch schon anbraten
French Toast in die heiße Pfanne und von
allen Seiten goldbraun backen wenige
Minuten später sind sie perfekt
goldbraun angebacken jetzt toppen wir
das ganze noch mit unserer Soße vertraut
mir das ist das perverseste Frühstück
was ihr je Essen werdet
und das wirklich 10 von Z von Zeh von Z
von ze von Z macht's unbedingt nach